were you surprised about that switch  from streamer to  top class world-class player again  i mean nakamura has always been great  but i mean  but i do think um nakamura's gonna  um he's got a lot of confidence  um  from  from playing online events um  and winning so much  the last few years  um  and  i mean he used to be a perennial  top-time player so i mean there's no  doubt that he can he can play and you  could you also saw the final of the tour  in 2020  um  he posed a lot of problems for me  and  also he was really well prepared  yeah uh he was also pretty well prepared  when he played  over the board rapping and blitzen in  saint louis last year so there's no  doubt that once he plays over the board  he takes these events very seriously  um  [Music]  so  yeah it's a surprise for me to see him  do this well but um  it's it's not um it's not a shock he has  the he has the ability